° fait assez froid mais c'est dû au fait
que la plupart des berlinois de l'est
ont dépensé beaucoup d'argent hier ils
avaient le droit à 102 tu marques par
personne et ils ont vraiment envahi tous
les magasins est donc aujourd'hui il ya
un petit peu moins de monde en plus des
magasins de berlin ouest ont pu ouvrir
quand même mais tous les allemands de
l'est ne savent pas que les magasins
sont ouverts donc il ya un peu moins de
monde alors ça va après la poignée de
main entre les deux maires de berlin-est
et berlin-ouest monsieur mon père il ya
eu donc nouveaux passages ouverts et
nous nous sommes rendus à ce passage
pour voir ces berlinois qui revenait ou
qu'ils venaient pour la première fois à
berlin on reste regardez c'est le
huitième passage ouverts à travers le
mur de berlin et malgré le froid matinal
ils étaient plusieurs centaines à
vouloir passer leur dimanche à l'ouest
c'est la première fois pour vous et
votre garçon et vous êtes contents dans
l'est à l'ouest
oui bien sûr qu'est ce que vous allez
faire d'abord regarder et vous avez des
deux marques
j'ai changé 15 marques 70 francs vous
avez assez d'argent
on en a pas besoin ce matin il passait
dix par 10 pour éviter les débordements
de foule
l'armée a mis en place des bureaux
individuels et portatif pour apposer
plus vite et plus facilement le visa de
la liberté qui permet d'entrer et de
revenir comme on veut en allemagne de
l'est
les ouvertures du mur se font
progressivement l'armée populaire et
c'est ici de contenir la poussée de la
foule qui tentent de forcer la brèche à
l'ouest on a beau démolir le mur un
certain ordre doit être respecté le
temps de l'euphorie d'hier est passé ce
qu'ils ont dépensé tout leur argent 350
francs offerts par l'allemagne fédérale
ne repasseront pas aujourd'hui on sait
qu'hier 500000 berlinois de l'est sont
passés à l'ouest et qu'ils seront sans
doute autant aujourd'hui comme ici au
métro friedrichstrasse aux voyages
gratuits pour les allemands de l'est
un allemand sur cinq a ainsi obtenu un
visa pour passer à l'ouest
et la plupart reviennent au pays
ce qui fait dire que le pari de
l'ouverture du mur de berlin pour
freiner l'exode de la population et peut
être gagner